[Musique]
ça fait quand même pas mal d'années que
j'avais entendu de parler d'un truc qui
s'appelait le cam siècle mais j'avais
vaguement entendu parler ce truc là et
moi j'avais un pote qui est probable
qu'ils pratiquent et enfin qu'ils
étaient travailleurs du sexe et qu'il
utilisait pour bosser il était ma soeur
et qu'il est utilisé en dehors aussi
c'est à dire aussi pour partouzer quoi
donc en fait il passait son temps dans
le calme sec ce match était beaucoup
chez lui et c'est comme ça que j'ai
découvert un peu cet univers c'est quoi
le sexe alors le quément sexe est une
pratique sexuelle qui consiste à ajouter
des drogues spécifiques souvent des
drogues de synthèse ou des
méthamphétamines dont les ports pimenter
les débats les parties pour pimenter des
partouzes mais pas que le départ tous
pour pimenter le sexe pour booster le
plaisir et la performance aussi de la
party games peuvent quand même duré 48
heures trois jours quatre jours donc les
descentes
voilà déjà canton d'is par les quatre
jours sur une semaine il reste plus que
trois jours après ces trois jours de
descente les cas m'utiliser par par
leucan sexe quelque chose de très crue
ça devient très vestiaires la boîte à
fantasmes
elle fonctionne elle va vraiment dans la
surenchère et et aussi les limites on
les casse vite c'est à dire que c'est
pas rare qu'un ken secteur est
complètement ce qu'il a fait la veille
avec des partenaires qui lui plaisait
pas des pratiques qui lui plaisait pas
ou ou des pratiques même à risque et
donc donc je dirais que ça ça ça touche
peut-être jeu dira ce qu'il ya de plus
bestial en nous quand on est sous
l'influencé de ces produits là une des
problématiques du cam sexe c'est que
c'est un plan de la sexualité
alors alors y en a qui avec le temps
qu'il voilà qui sait quelque chose qui
revient il ya une réelle éducation
peuvent faire avec ça mais une fois
qu'ils ont connu le plaisir maximal
c'est sûr que souvent les teams sexeur
les retours c'est que maintenant je fais
quoi moi je ma sexualité me paraît me
parler place pour moi dans le phénomène
du kent sexe chez blake n 6 heures les
ceux qui ont cette habitude le sexe
m'annoncer le sait ce qui participe au
déni c'est un prétexte pour se défoncer
c'est à dire que d'ailleurs souvent ça
termine sa termine souvent dans l'
isolement
complet où la personne est en train de
se défoncer devant des sites style zoom
ou en train de se mater des ports noël
se défonce tout seul ça se termine dans
l'isolément et le sexe devient vite un
prétexte pour défoncer pour moi ce qui
domine dans lequel sexe n'est pas le
sexe l'accablent ça concerne plaindre
beaucoup de drogues de synthèse ce qu'on
appelle des cathinones condé non un peu
bizarre quatre mecs très même celles
aussi la crystal christelle
méthamphétamine voilà c'est plein de le
gbl ce qu'on appelle plus communément le
ghb voilà effectivement il ya plein de
cannes qui tourne autour de cette
pratique de ce phénomène
ça ressemble à quoi c'est drôle c'est
des trucs qu'on peut fumer sniffer
ploguer ingérée et shooter dans le
bas-rhin et voilà il ya plein de façons
de l'utiliser c'est qu'il ya des sites
concrètement où il y assure sur un des
partenaires mais quelqu'un qui veut un
partenaire sexuel il voit ce qu'il a
exactement
j'ai de la 3ème mcg ça tout est indiqué
et même les pratiques sexuelles
on est vraiment sur le marché du sexe
vraiment c'est un marché c'est devenu un
marché à ciel ouvert qui mélange le sexe
et la camo c'est comme ça que ça marche
et c'est comme ça que sont organisés
beaucoup de partout c'est à dire le tel
et tel partenaire et c'est par elles
mêmes dans les tous de voir des gens en
pleine toulouse avec leur téléphone pour
faire venir pour se barrer une auto pour
se barrer à une autre tous ou faire
venir d'autres d'autres partenaires
[Musique]
la part de réalité et de fiction
elle est facile à dire c'est que
l'histoire est complètement fictive mais
que les personnages des situations des
scènes l'ambiance le milieu est vrai de
même des personnages qu'ils sont c'est
comme ça tout le temps que j'ai inscrit
mes romans c'est à dire à partir de à
partir de matériaux très vrai jeu
j'invente une train et c'est ce que j'ai
fait c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait
dans le livre quoi le personnage de z
n'est pas moi moi ce que je peux dire là
dessus c'est que j'ai consommé ces
produits là j'ai été amené à consommer
ces produits là et qu'effectivement ça
me développe quelque chose de très
bestial au moins ça me fait partir dans
des fantasmes qui ne plaisent pas si
j'ai pas consommer quoi en fait
le point de départ finalement c'est l'un
des personnages de 10 c'est le truc du
moment dans la communauté gay ouais est
ce qu'aujourd'hui en vrai pas seulement
dans le roman c'est le truc du moment
d'accueillir à moi je pense que c'est la
problématique des de la communauté gay
d'ailleurs il ya un article est sorti
récemment du du new york times qui est
capelle il ce phénomène le cido numéro 2
donc est d'ailleurs y'a pas que ça il ya
beaucoup d'associations qui commence à
l'appeler comme ça vu que le cam sexe
est en train de se généraliser et qu'il
ya de plus en plus de morts et que et
qu'il ya de plus en plus de dégâts et
que aussi ça arrive chez les hétéros et
je pense que ça c'est ça aussi qui peut
alerter parce que quand c'est relégué à
une communauté je pense que ça intéresse
moins que si le phénomène est
généralisée je pense qu'effectivement
les pouvoirs publics vont commencer à
s'y intéresser de plus en plus